texas governor greg abbott recently
lifted the mask mandate and allowed
businesses to reopen at 100
capacity you might ask why would they do
such a thing when scientists are against
it
when doctors or nurses are begging us to
hold on just a little bit longer
simple cause texas rocks
[Music]
took one brave governor to decree he
cares about texas and he'll set us
free if people have to die for my
liberty
that my governor says so be it it's been
too long i've had enough
i won't wear a mask cause i don't give
up if you think i'm wrong
you can kiss my butt it's time to
celebrate our freedom
we just don't care
get this
[Music]
texas just don't give up
all night and day i don't care what
they're sad to say
they tell us no we open up anyway and
when i see a stranger i kiss
he doesn't know signs but he knows
what's right he's a leader in this big
dumb fight
because he's old rich and white he got
the vaccine weeks ago
i could say
sure i can't but it's not
like i'm super mad
[Music]
we're texas
[Applause]
you